scott disick spotted with key women for  a night out in New York City Kourtney  Kardashian's ex was out until around  five a.m. with a mysterious blonde and  her brunette friend in these exclusive  pics you can see Scott has cuts on his  hand and a rip in his coat Scott met  with the two women for dinner at koi in  Soho around 10pm from there they went to  up and down nightclub for an hour then  to a soho house party this isn't Scott's  first night of partying in the Big Apple  he hosted a private event at 1oak on  Friday night Scott checked out of rehab  in November after a month of treatment  the topic has been a storyline on recent  episodes of Keeping Up with the  Kardashians he's like an 80s silver and  I just want to you know really get it  together this time like for my kids I am  surprised that Scott has gone to rehab  just because I feel like I was just  hearing he was on the streets partying